achtung für alle autofahrer das müssen
sie wissen denn im nächsten jahr müssen
alle ihren führerschein abgeben
natürlich nicht für immer aber sie
werden doch gezwungen ihren
liebgewonnenen grauen oder rosafarbenen
lappen also diese hier gegen eine
plastikkarte einzutauschen das betrifft
ja also vor allem so also in meiner
generation fängt schon an ich habe doch
so ein rosa nicht mit aber leider
verloren aber ich hab's im rosendekor
sein führerschein verloren ja schon die
plastikkarte ach so du hast ihn ich
dachte musste den führerschein abgeben
eine wurde geschehen war schon gespannt
was du zu erzählen hast aber was sagen
sie eigentlich dazu zu diesen neuen
regeln dass sie ihren alten lappen
abgeben müssen wir haben sie gefragt
wussten sie eigentlich dass ihr
führerschein bald abläuft ich zumindest
nicht steht auch irgendwo auf dieser
kleinen grauen karte hintergrund dieser
umtauschpflicht ist eine neue
eu-richtlinie die besagt dass jeder bis
2033 einen neuen einheitlichen vor allem
fälschungssicheren führerschein hat was
immer wieder für verwirrung sorgt jetzt
ist dass es je nach altersklasse und vor
allem je nach ausstellungsdatum des
führerscheins eine andere frist gibt wir
haben es jetzt hier in der hamburger
innenstadt mal umgehört wer davon schon
was gehört hat
würde sie das jetzt so ein bisschen
traurig machen dass man den jetzt
abgeben muss absolut nicht da habe ich
seit jetzt was schon 96 54 24 jahre
wieso ist das abgeben möchte ich auch
nicht aufgeben also wo ein teil von mir
finden ist ein bisschen schade den
nostalgischen alten führerschein abgeben
zu müssen nein mir ist das eigentlich
egal
hauptsache ich kann fahren er muss man
das geld ja wieder reinholen macht man
halt mal neuen fahrzeug nicht machen wir
müssen gar eine prüfung machen und sie
müssen nein ich weiß aber trotzdem ist
es natürlich bei allen sachen so das
geld muss rein also werden wieder neue
regeln aufgestellt also ich finde ich
sentimental ich liebe diesen grauen
lappen nicht die kleine karte finde ich
schon schicker aber dass das nun sein
muss unbedingt finde ich eher lästig
finden sie das macht sinn
neuerdings zeit denke ich läuft alles
über karten ich ja ich sag mal schon für
die zukunft würde ich sagen wenn ich
mein auto mit ist es viel einfacher als
sowas und würden sie den rosa lappen
bisschen vermissen total das yakult
warum wird sie das besonders ärgern wenn
der rosa lappen weg wäre weil meine
schönen führerscheinklassen nicht
behalten dürfen lkw fahren und 125er
nach der neuen nicht dass ich mir das
umtauschen wieder das wahrscheinlich
auch wieder mit unheimlichen kosten
verbunden die den steuerzahlerinnen
irgendwie viel geld kostet das verstehe
ich nicht fazit hier bei uns in hamburg
auf der straße 9 statt die meisten leute
haben von der neuen richtlinie noch
nichts gehört und wollten uns auch nicht
so recht glauben dass es diese geben
soll wir hoffen dass sich das bis 2022
geändert hat wenn die richtlinie dann
wirklich umgesetzt wird
weg mit dem alten lappen also für viele
unserer zuschauer ist es noch 9 und
genau deswegen wollen wir darüber
aufklären weil bei vielen das herz dran
hängt an dem rosa ding du hast es
mitgebracht michael quandt aus unserer
service redaktion auch bei dir eine
altes ding mit ich habe
das ja das bin ich
es sollte man doch patrick hat erkannt
1987 gemacht den führerschein und auch
ich werde daran hängen aber wie gesagt
ab 2022 werden sukzessive 43 millionen
führerscheine rosa oder grau in eine
plastikkarte umgetauscht warum die eu
hat sich darauf geeinigt dass wir in der
eu einen einheitlichen führerschein habe
er überall gelesen werden kann der
überall anerkannt wird und der vor allen
dingen fälschungssicher ist diese großer
pappe ist halt relativ leicht zu
fälschen und die neuen führerscheine
sind dann europaweit auslesbar hat auch
noch andere vorteile ich werde jetzt in
italien oder spanien kontrolliert von
der polizei mit dem
scheint kann nicht jeder was anfangen
die karte kennt dann jeder weise in
europa gleich ist auch bei der anmietung
eines mietwagens zum beispiel im ausland
am flughafen geht das alles etwas
einfacher dann mit dieser plastikkarte
es ist kriegt man ja an manchen amt
nicht meinen termin um sich einen neuen
reisepass oder ähnliches zu besorgen und
deshalb 43 millionen führerscheine
umgetauscht werden wie soll das denn
klappen michael ja das haben die sich
ganz clever ausgedacht es wird auf elf
jahre gestreckt und je nach geburtsjahr
kriegt man sozusagen sein slot zugeteilt
war man tauschen soll also zum beispiel
bei mir ich bin jahrgang 68
ich muss meinen führerschein umgetauscht
haben bis zum 19 erst 2024 und wie das
ende dann 2033 von jahr zu jahr
jüngeren sind später dran die jünger ja
genau da würde dann würde ich sagen
besteht eine gewisse chance hier in
berlin einen termin zu bekommen
rechtzeitig ja um das suchen wir
eventuell hinhauen michael was ist aber
wenn dein herz jetzt vor allen dingen an
diesem foto an dieser rosa pappe so sehr
hängt das du sagst ich mache da nicht
mit ich tausche mich um was du strafe
zahlen ja das kostet bei jedes mal
erwischt werden kostet das zehn euro ist
jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel aber man
sollte es als wiederholungstäter dann
sicherlich auch lassen aber beim
führerschein ist es dann so wie beim
reisepass oder personalausweis wenn man
an dem alten hängt und noch ein visum
dran hat dann wird halt ungültig
gestempelt noch hier wird der
führerschein dann wahrscheinlich einfach
gelacht werden also man darf ihn
aufheben aus nostalgie gründen in die
schublade packen aber irgendwann braucht
man diese kleine scheckkarte im
portemonnaie und was brauche ich dann
alles also wenn ich jetzt meinen
terminen berliner abend in fünf jahren
vereinbart habe was muss ich mitbringen
damit dann in fünf jahren mein termin
nicht etwa verschoben wird weil ich
irgendwas vergessen habe ein aktuelles
passfoto den alten führerschein
personalausweis oder reisepass und 25
euro aber und jetzt kommt die falle bist
du in deinem leben einmal umgezogen und
wo uns nicht mehr an dem ort an dem der
führerschein ausgestellt wurde dann
brauchst du eine abschrift von der
führerscheinstelle bei der ausgestellt
wurde die dann nach berlin geschickt
wird
bei mir wäre das halte ich müsste anhalt
in essen die abschriften anzufangen oder
ja das wird super laufen einzig
positive daran ist man muss wohl nicht
selber vorstellig werden an der in der
alten führerscheinstelle sondern man
soll das telefonisch per e mail oder
auch bei den moderneren ämtern also
nicht aufhalten per online machen können
das ist fantastisch der bildteil
zuversichtlich dass das richtig gut
funktionieren wird bei 43 millionen
dieser lappen apropos passfoto das
müssen wir noch mal zeigen michael zeigt
uns noch einmal dein herz foto um
nochmal zu checken ja das ist unser
lieber kollege michael quandt erzähl mal
ganz kurz was war das findet zeit in der
du deinen führerschein gemacht hast und
ganz wichtig bist du durch gefallen oder
hat es gleich geklappt nein es hat auf
anhieb geklappt in der theoretischen
prüfung habe ich die maximal fehlerzahl
erreicht
gerade noch so durchgekommen und in der
in der praxis ich habe es einer
kleinstadt in velbert in nordrhein
westfalen gemacht viele einbahnstraßen
aber nach relativ kurzen 20 minuten die
prüfung war damals kürzer bin ich da bin
ich durchgekommen und seitdem war er
auch nie weg der führerschein oder doch
[Gelächter]
[Musik]